ce soir à 18 heures sur public sénat
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat nous allons tout de suite prendre
la direction de l'hémicycle pour les
questions cribles les sénateurs
interpelle un ministre sur un thème et
cette semaine et bien les élus se
penchent sur l'avenir des retraites la
ministre marisol touraine est là dans
l'hémicycle pour répondre à leurs
questions bonne séance atos est plus usé
physiquement dont nombre d'entreprises
se séparent sans scrupules elle prolonge
l'activité d'autres salariés ce qui
freine considérablement l'entrée des
jeunes dans la vie professionnelle
c'est la situation des comptes sociaux
exigent réellement une réforme de son
financement
cette réforme ne peut se faire contre
les six relaxes contre les salariés car
ces derniers ne sont pas le problème ils
sont la solution
madame la ministre la réforme des
retraites exige des mesures justes et
solidaire à l'opposé de celle proposée
par l'ump et le medef
pour autant vous semblez ne pas vouloir
vous écarter des choix des gouvernements
précédents que vous rejetez hier et
pourtant lourdes conséquences pour le
monde du travail
ne croyez vous pas qu'il ira enfin tant
que le capital l'argent de la
spéculation qui aujourd'hui d'être is
plus d'emplois qu'il n'en crée soient
mobilisés et mis à contribution pour une
réforme des retraites qui soit juste et
viable garantissant le droit à la
retraite à 60 ans sans décote
sans nouvel allongement de la durée de
cotisation car prenant l'argent là où il
est pour la réponse la parole est à mme
ana marisol touraine ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vaquerin nous avons engagé la
discussion sur l'avenir de nos régimes
de retraites il y a un an avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
à l'occasion de la première grande
conférence sociale qui s'est tenu au
mois de juillet 2012 et à l'occasion de
cette rencontre un consensus s'est
dégagé pour considérer que
une réforme de notre système de
retraites était nécessaire ce qui
passait par la définition d'une méthode
et d'un calendrier
en effet nous avons et j'ai la volonté
au nom du gouvernement de rompre
explicitement clairement avec la
démarche engagée par le précédent
gouvernement qui a fait du passage en
force sa marque de fabrique et qui a
fait du relèvement de l'âge légal le
seul enjeu de la réforme passée avec les
résultats que l'on connaît résultats
d'inefficacité sur le plan financier
résultat d'injustice sur le plan social
et c'est parce que nous avons la volonté
d'engager une réforme qui soit à la fois
responsable sur le plan financier est
juste que nous entamons des discussions
après avoir je vous le rappelle monsieur
le sénateur pris un décret dès notre
arrivée aux responsabilités qui permet à
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler jeunes de partis en retraite
dès 60 ans sans attendre soixante deux
ans après le diagnostic réalisé par le
conseil d'orientation des retraites
la commission présidée par madame ans
mauro présentera ou des pistes de
travail à partir desquels va s'engager
une concertation longue et approfondie
menée par le gouvernement avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
je vous le dis monsieur le sénateur nous
n'avons pas une volonté de
précipitations nous avons la volonté
d'élaborer à partir d'orientation
sérieuse et crédible
une réforme qui rassure les jeunes
générations sur l'avenir du système de
retraite
souhaitez-vous répliqué sur votre 1
tu réellement comme vous nous souhaitons
que cette réforme soit construite de
manière juste et solidaire et c'est
possible car des pistes alternatives à
celles du rapport moreau existe si on a
vraiment le courage de s'attaquer à la
question de la répartition des richesses
un exemple entre 1985 et 2007 la
rémunération des actionnaires est passé
de 3,2 pour cent du pib à 8,5 ce qui
représente pas moins de 100 milliards
d'euros versés annuellement aux
actionnaires dans le même temps la part
des salaires dans la valeur ajoutée n'a
cessé de diminuer
en taxant le capital au même niveau que
le travail il est possible de générer
annuellement 20 milliards d'euros de
recettes rien que pour le financement
des retraites
fidèle aux positions qu'il a toujours
porté ce sont ces propositions que le
groupe crc défendra et je regrette
madame les ministres que ces pistes
économiquement viable et socialement
justes ne soit pas plus sérieusement
explorées par le gouvernement la parole
est maintenant monsieur jean désessard
pour le groupe écologiste quand on vit
plus longtemps on peut travailler plus
longtemps
cette petite musique s'installe comme un
air qu'on entend de plus en plus
régulièrement
mais pour qu'une telle solution puisse
être ne serait-ce qu envisageable il
faudrait pour cela qu'ils y travaillent
or s'agissant de l'emploi des 55 64 ans
je cite la france se distingue par un
décrochage particulièrement
particulièrement marquée de la
participation au marché du travail à
partir de 55 ans il s'agit d'une
citation d'un rapport de l'insee
intitulée en.fr 2013 paru le 6 mars
dernier avec un taux d'emploi de 40%
chez les seniors
la france se place derrière l'espagne le
portugal et même la grèce donc première
observation travailler plus longtemps
pour 60 % des seniors est ce possible
alors qu'ils sont au chômage
actuellement chez les jeunes
le taux de chômage dépasse on l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises ici quant à lui les
25% pour quelles raisons les seniors
trouverait un emploi plus facilement
les jeunes s'il n'y a pas assez de
travail alors faisons travailler les
jeunes à longer la côte y durée de
cotisation sans résoudre ce problème
n'aura que pour seul effet de baisser
les pensions de retraite de jean qui
n'arriveront pas à obtenir suffisamment
d'années de travail pour financer leur
retraite dont l'augmentation de la durée
de cotisation contribuera dans l'état
actuel du marché du travail à faire
baisser les cotisations de ceux qui
n'ont plus d'emploi après 55 ans et
repousser le versement des allocations
de ceux qui ont un emploi
d'où l'économie mais alors les jeunes
auront-ils du travail donc la question
qui est posée madame la ministre avec la
l'augmentation de la durée des
cotisations
n'est ce pas le marché du travail des
jeunes et bien que on oublia problème
puisque justement si on dit aux gens
continuer de travailler de en plus
longtemps et bien c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va améliorer le chômage des jeunes
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
pour répondre à monsieur décès ça oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur la prise en compte de
l'espérance de vie est un facteur que
nous ne pouvons pas méconnaître comme
cela a été indiqué précédemment
d'ailleurs nous devons être attentifs au
fait que cette espérance de vie n'est
pas la même selon les catégories
socioprofessionnelles et un ouvrier à 35
ans a une espérance de vie qui est de 5
6 ans inférieure à celle d'un cadre au
même âge
si l'on prend en compte l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé on s'aperçoit que
l'écart est encore plus important ce qui
veut dire que nous devons être attentifs
à faire en sorte que les conditions de
travail la pénibilité l'âge d'entrée
dans la vie professionnelle soit des
facteurs qui soit intégrée dans la
manière dont nous concevons nos régimes
de retraite pour autant il est vrai que
nous vivons collectivement plus
longtemps mais que la question du temps
consacré au travail et poser dès lors
que l'on a vis plus longtemps il paraît
juste au moins de s'interroger sur la
possibilité de travailler plus longtemps
encore faut-il comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le sénateur que le travail soit
possible et que en réalité il n'y est
pas tout simplement des transferts de
verre l'unedic et vert l'allocation
chômage
je veux d'abord vous faire observer que
le taux d'emploi des plus de 55 ans a
augmenté significativement au cours des
dernières années et que par ailleurs il
va de soi qu'une réforme des retraites
doit s'accompagner de mesures fortes en
direction de l'emploi et de l'emploi des
seniors le gouvernement a d'ores et déjà
commencé à y travailler pour la question
de l'emploi indépendamment de celle des
retraites
en mettant en place les contrats de
génération qui ont précisément pour
enjeu de maintenir dans l'emploi des
seniors et nous avons à nous inspirer de
mesures qui ont été prises dans les pays
du nord pour renforcer le taux d'emploi
des seniors à l'évidence une réforme des
retraites et la politique de l'emploi
sont indissociablement liés monsieur dsa
eaux souterraines réplique
ouais je ne peux être que d'accord avec
la conclusion madame la ministre que
l'emploi et les retraites sont très liés
puisque les cotisations chômage sont
basés sur justement l'emploi et si tout
le monde a un emploi
eh bien ça veut dire qu'il ya plus de
cotisations donc mais pour revenir sur
la question de l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation madame la ministre
j'aime et de fortes réserves si ça
s'applique à tout le monde vous l'avez
dit vous-même puisque la concurrence
effrénée entre les pays et l'application
des recettes issues de la mondialisation
n'aboutit bien souvent qu'à une seule
chose la casse des acquis sociaux
conquis par des générations de
travailleurs sur le temps de travail ou
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
d'ailleurs voté sous des gouvernements
de gauche et les effets de cette case
peuvent être dramatiques
une étude de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé de 2008 sur les liens entre
déterminants sociaux et espérance de vie
ainsi démontré que dans une ville comme
glasgow en
cos l'espérance de vie dans les
quartiers les plus pauvres de cette
ville est désormais de 54 ans alors
qu'elle est de 82 ans dans les quartiers
les plus riches donc on voit bien
l'inégalité si on le met pour tout le
monde vous concluez je vais donc
conclure donc madame la ministre je vous
donne rendez vous pour résoudre pour
débattre plus de cette question à
l'automne mais vous comprendrez que nous
aurons très attentif sur les mesures que
vous prendrez pour l'emploi de pour
l'ensemble de la population et en
particulier pour les jeunes
la parole est maintenant monsieur
gilbert barbier pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues avec un
déficit évalué à 20 milliards d'euros en
2020 le dossier des retraites est
explosif comme l'avait laissé entendre
il ya bien autant michel rocard dès que
nous l'avez vous écoutez cette époque
depuis l'ancienne majorité a entrepris
plusieurs réformes n'est forcé
d'admettre qu'elles ne suffiront pas
surtout dans la conjoncture économique
actuelle
vous remettez aujourd'hui l'ouvragé sur
le métier je ne peux que saluer cette
initiative
s'ils tentaient que vous traitiez les
véritables causes de ce déficit
chronique
le rapport que madame yannick moreau
s'apprête à vous remettre demain forme
une boîte à outils dans laquelle le
gouvernement pourra piocher
il propose notamment de rapprocher les
règles de calcul des pensions de la
fonction publique sur celle de ces clubs
privés aborde-t-il l'ensemble des
régimes spéciaux
malgré les réformes des dix dernières
années qui ont opéré une certaine
convergence sont très différents régimes
des disparités majeurs subsistent vous
le savez qui alimente régulièrement la
chronique avec plus ou moins de vérité
ou de fantasmes
nous devons aborder cette question dans
un esprit de responsabilité en disant
cela je m'adresse aussi bien à ceux qui
cherchent à opposer les uns aux autres
qu'à ceux qui s'accrochent un contrat
initial souvent dépassé
vous l'avez dit madame laminer ses
efforts de vente est partagé par tous
une réforme qui épargnerait certaines
catégories salariés ne serait pas
comprise
il faut certes tenir compte des diverses
situations des contraintes liées aux
services publics aux conditions de
travail etc
mais quoi qu'il en soit je ne suis pas
convaincu que les mesures proposées par
le rapport moreau soit suffisante à
ouvrir des perspectives durables
pouvons-nous faire aujourd'hui
l'économie d'une réflexion sur les
fondements même de notre système de
retraite à la française le lien exclusif
entre travail et cotisations prestations
est il toujours pertinents il faut avoir
l'audace d'ouvrir ce débat vous avez la
parole madame la ministre monsieur merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur en barbier la question du
financement de la protection sociale est
un enjeu de réflexion qui évidemment
occupent les discussions que le
gouvernement peut avoir avec les
partenaires sociaux
pour autant nous sommes aujourd'hui
confrontés à une situation en matière de
retraite qui appelle des réponses
rapides à la fois sur le court terme
puisque nous savons que le déséquilibre
financier de nos régimes d'ici 2020 est
important mais aussi sur le long terme
car c'est nous voulons redonner
confiance aux jeunes générations dans un
système de retraite solidaire nous avons
le devoir d' inscrire une réforme dans
la durée pour ce pour cela il paraît
très dangereux et je souscris à vos
propos d'opposer les français les uns
aux autres et certaines catégories les
unes aux autres on entend beaucoup
depuis quelques jours une petite musique
qui consisterait à expliquer qu'au fond
pour résoudre le problème des retraites
il suffirait de s'en prendre aux à la
situation des fonctionnaires on entend
une petite musique qui consiste à
expliquer que les fonctionnaires sont
des privilégiés certains d'ailleurs
appartenant à l'ancienne majorité
appellent de leurs voeux des big bang et
ne sont pas à une approximation près
lorsqu'il compare le niveau de retraite
des uns et des autres prenant la
retraite complète des fonctionnaires
d'un côté pour la comparer à une partie
seulement de la retraite des salariés du
privé
la retraite de base oubliant de dire que
cette retraite de base est évidemment
complétée par une retraite
complémentaire obligatoire et que quand
on veut faire des comparaisons
on essaye de comparer des choses qui
sont comparables
mais au-delà de cela la situation des
fonctionnaires doit être replacée dans
un ensemble plus vaste les règles de
calcul des pensions ne sont pas les
mêmes assurément mais la situation dans
la fonction publique et dans le privé ne
tourne pas systématiquement al'avantage
de la fonction publique contrairement à
ce que l'on entend est donc si les
fonctionnaires ne doivent évidemment pas
rester à l'écart d'une réforme à venir
il n'est pas envisageable d'en faire des
boucs émissaires de la situation de nos
régimes de retraite
monsieur barbier souhaitez vous
effectuez réplique oui mais la ministre
entend bien à ce que vous dites
concernant les fonctionnaires mais sur
la question voulait pas prononcé le mot
des régimes spéciaux
là je crois qu'il faudra quand même
aborder ce problème et je ne pense pas
que c'est en stigmatisant l'ancienne
majorité comme vous avez quand même
souvent l'habitude de faire que nous
pourrons aborder sainement ce problème
des retraites c'est un problème qui nous
concerne tous on a peut-être des
solutions qui peuvent diverger
je crois qu'il faut surtout essayer de
trouver un consensus entre non seulement
la majorité et l'opposition mais aussi
avec les différentes catégories sociales
qui sont touchés par ce problème
je remercie la parole est maintenant
monsieur gérard larcher pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire oui
monsieur le président madame la ministre
et chers collègues le système des
retraites est un des indicateurs d'un
modèle social celui que nous avons mis
en place il y a longtemps dans notre
pays est basée sur la solidarité des
générations
il est depuis longtemps en difficulté et
celles et ceux qui l'ont préservée
défendu ce sont les gouvernements
d'edouard balladur de jacques chirac
jean pierre raffarin et françois fillon
puis en 2003 les gouvernements sous
l'autorité de nicolas sarkozy avec
françois fillon
beaucoup a été fait mais la réalité liée
à notre taux d'activité notre
démographie notre situation économique
et sociale n'est qu'il nous faut
poursuivre et approfondir encore les
réformes engagées au fond
il faut inverser ce qui a été décidé
sans étude prospective simplement par un
choix politique c'était la proposition
82 de françois mitterrand en 1981 la
retraite à 60 ans était sympathique et
pourtant des élus aussi peu
réactionnaire que philippe seguin et
jacques chaban delmas avait prévenu et
je cite par les coûts supplémentaires
qui pèseront sur des régimes de retraite
déjà en difficulté
le gouvernement prend le risque de
compromettre l'avenir alors aujourd'hui
il va falloir et à contre-pied d'une
attitude constante de la gauche depuis
20 ans examinés l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation la contribution de
tous la convergence progressive des
trans un système pour ma part attaché à
l'équité je prendrai le courage de
parler du report de l'âge mais en
prenant en compte la pénibilité et le
taux d'activité des seniors qui est un
vrai sujet de la convergence progressive
des régimes publics privés et spéciaux
sans oublier qu'il ya des fonctionnaires
je pense notamment aux territoriaux dont
les retraites sont modestes
mon refus de voir comme paramètre la
désindexation et nous voyons bien que ce
sujet est entré subrepticement dans le
cadre de la négociation agirc arrco et
sans doute at il une indexation sur la
croissance
vous l'avez dit vous-même quand on vit
plus longtemps on peut travailler plus
longtemps alors ma question est double
appliquerez vous le dispositif de la loi
de 2010 adoptée ici sur la réforme du
système et dont je rappelle que dans la
loi nous devons mettre en place des
groupes de travail
cette année certes il faudra du temps
mais comme la cfdt je crois qu'il ya là
une voix qui répond à la pérennité et
l'équité et vitré vous de paupériser les
retraités vous êtes au pied du mur
madame la ministre
est ce que vous n'avez pas fait en nous
accompagnant depuis 20 ans il va falloir
aujourd'hui le faire sans faux fuyant
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement n'a
pas l'intention de prendre
quelques chemins de traverse que ce soit
et il n'a pas l'intention non plus de se
laisser dicter une réforme parce qu il y
a deux ans prétendait répondre à
l'ensemble des défis que rencontrent nos
régimes de retraites pour que nous nous
trouvions deux ans après aujourd'hui
trois ans mais deux ans après avec le
constat implacable d'un déficit qui
s'accroît et d'une justice sociale battu
en brèche et donc le gouvernement va
mettre en place la concertation
nécessaire pour mettre en pla pour
proposer une réforme globale qui ne soit
pas simplement une réforme comptable car
les réformes comptable ne permettent pas
de répondre aux grands enjeux liés à la
question de la retraite mais une réforme
qui inscrivent dans la durée à la fois
nos régimes de retraite par répartition
et la solidarité entre les générations
la volonté du gouvernement et qu'à
l'occasion de la réforme qu'ils engagent
soit garanti le financement de
l'ensemble des régimes de retraite d'ici
2020 que soit donnée ou rendu confiance
aux jeunes générations dans l'avenir de
nos systèmes de retraite en introduisant
des mécanismes de financement de ces
régimes
à un horizon plus lointain et en
envisageant des dispositifs qui
permettent régulièrement de revoir la
situation financière de ces régimes et
enfin réforme qui doit proposer des
mesures de justice car et vous l'avez
vous-même indiqué nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui à des personnes qui ont de
toutes petites retraites je pense en
particulier à certains agriculteurs
je pense par exemple aux femmes je pense
à celles et ceux qui ont eu des
carrières hachées et c'est donc cette
vision globale que nous voulons porter
dans le cadre du système de retraite par
répartition car monsieur le sénateur la
réforme que nous engageons évidemment
vos remise à plat des systèmes et de la
réforme de 2010 c'est avec les
partenaires sociaux le travail que nous
avons mises en place pour que l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et en particulier
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui
s'interrogent sur l'avenir de leur
retraite puisse compter sur des pensions
de niveaux satisfaisants et qui leur
permettent
visage et l'avenir avec sérénité pour
une courte réplique monsieur le
président mais le président on aime la
ministre au delà des mots il va avoir eu
la nécessité de prendre des décisions
mais pardonnez moi ces décisions ça ne
pouvait pas être qu'un ensemble de mots
sympathique chaleureux
il y aura des réalités et parmi ces
réalités là il y aura la convergence
qu'on le veuille ou non le système de
retraite et parmi les réalités il y aura
la réflexion sur la contribution des uns
et des autres avec en même temps quand
on parle de compétitivité d'emploi et
bien la réalité qu'on ne peut pas peser
ni sur les entreprises nées sur les
salariés
car cette réalité là elle va s'imposer à
nous et je dois dire que attaché que je
suis au système par répartition je pense
que nous devons refonder progressivement
le système ça se passera pas j'allais
dire en un tour de main
mais s'il ne le faisons pas comme nous
en avons décidé le principe en 2010
collectivement je me souviens du débat
alors nous aurons manquer ce rendez vous
à tous les cas vous êtes au pied du mur
si vous prenez les bonnes décisions
on les soutiendra mais si vous prenez
les chemins de traverse
nous serons au travers de sécheval à la
parole est un monsieur jean marie
vanlerenberghe pour les le groupe union
des démocrates et indépendants
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
selon le cor le besoin de financement
des retraites se creusera régulièrement
jusqu'en 2020 pour atteindre 20
milliards d'euros
ce déséquilibre est liée au
vieillissement de la population au
chômage mais aussi à l'inéquité
persistante du système
je devrais dire des 35 systèmes
différents différence de taux de
cotisation date d'ouverture des droits
de durée de cotisation de salaire de
référence le calcul des pensions demeure
très variable ce qui engendre bien sûr
un sentiment profond d'injustice
c'est particulièrement vrai lorsqu'on
compare le régime général au régime on
vient de le dire de la fonction publique
et aux régimes spéciaux qui coûte
plusieurs milliards d'euros l'évaluation
se portent entre 6 et 9 milliards
d'euros par an qu
tribuables et aux autres assurés sociaux
c'est pourquoi les membres de mon groupe
demande depuis plus de dix ans la
réforme structurelle consistant à
remplacer la nuitée par le point seul
moyen de rendre le système par
répartition équitable universel et juste
prenant compte par exemple la pénibilité
du travail et les arrêts pour maternité
chez les femmes sous notre impulsion la
loi de 2010 acter une telle évolution en
disposant dans son article et monsieur
gérard larcher vient de le rappeler dans
son article 16 qu'à compter du premier
semestre 2013
le comité de pilotage des régimes de
retraite organise une réflexion
nationale sur ce thème qu'en est-il
madame la ministre la réforme qui se
profile sera celle de l'équité de la
justice annoncée vous et au vu des
indiscrétions sur le rapport moreau et
des réactions qu'il a déjà suscité il
vous faudra du courage madame pour
affronter vos propres alliés sur ce
point
dans ces conditions madame la ministre
allez vous suivre la voie tracée par vos
prédécesseurs celle des ajustements
paramétrique qu'il faut revoir tous les
cinq ou six ans où allez vous écoutez
les réformistes de tous bords de plus en
plus nombreux sur tous les bancs ici et
est aussi à la cfdt chez les syndicats
qui demandent une réforme systémique
profonde seule capable de répondre
durablement la pérennité financière du
système par répartition et aux critères
de justice et d'équité qui sont les
vôtres mais aussi des nôtres
madame la ministre pour la réponse s'il
vous plaît merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur valeur enberg je
veux vous reconnaître une constance à
vous et à votre groupe vous avez défendu
de façon très régulière lee
et d'un système par points ce qui n'est
pas le cas de tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
se saisissent de cette possibilité pour
inventer une opposition au gouvernement
non vous ne l'avez pas voter puisque ça
n'a pas été voté autrement que comme une
étude et je me souviens des débats en
2010 où le groupe ump le groupe ump
avait marqué son opposition résolue à
cette perspective donc je vous reconnais
monsieur le sénateur sinon d'ailleurs la
réforme de 2010 aurait pu s'engager dans
cette voie là tout simplement
donc je vous reconnais monsieur le
sénateur une grande constance et je peux
vous dire que à l'occasion de la réforme
pour laquelle le gouvernement engage des
concertations toutes les options que les
partenaires sociaux souhaiteront
présenté est évoquée pourront faire
l'objet de discussions
même si je tiens à vous dire que au fond
la question d'une réforme par point
apparaît parfois encore une fois pas
dans votre bouche puisque vous êtes
constant mais apparaît parfois présentée
comme une solution miracle entre
guillemets celle qui permettrait de
dépasser les difficultés auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés en matière de
financement est l'exemple suédois qui
est fréquemment cité en exemple aller en
famille en avant l'exemple suédois
montrent que les enjeux de financement
ne se trouve pas résolu simplement par
le changement d'organisation des
systèmes de retraite et on s'est aperçu
dans ce pays qu'il avait fallu mettre en
place des dispositifs pour éviter la
baisse drastique des pensions qui était
versée au suédois en raison de la mise
en place de ce système par points
un système par points présentent
éventuellement l'intérêt de la
simplification
nous devons réfléchir à des propositions
en matière de simplification pli site et
plus grande de notre système le système
par points apparaît plus lisible la
volonté du gouvernement est de proposer
une réforme globale
mais la réforme par points ne permet pas
de résoudre des enjeux de financement la
parole est à monsieur vendre leur enberg
madame la ministre faudra nous présenter
effectivement une réforme globale qui
permette effectivement la pérennité des
financements je crois que justement la
réforme par point le père mais parce que
l' équilibre comptable est absolument
nécessaire
ce qui n'exclut pas de prendre en compte
tous les cas particuliers par des
bonifications par des décotes des
surcotes et je crois que la
simplification que le gouvernement et
que le président de la république nous a
promise passe par l'ajustement et ça
intéresse une très très grande majorité
de français et je crois que ça ne
pénalisera absolument pas ni les
systèmes actuels de fonctionnaires que
vous évidemment vous défendez je le
comprends
nous ne les attaquons pas non plus nous
souhaitons simplement qu'ils entrent
dans un système universel où chacun y
trouve son compte
merci beau la parole est à monsieur rené
teulade pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues depuis plus d'un
demi siècle
le secteur agricole a connu de
nombreuses mutations l'agriculture
traditionnelle et familiale séculaire en
france a été bouleversé par la
mécanisation la modernisation qui ont
engendré une diminution du besoin de
main d'oeuvre alors qu'auparavant les
exploitants agricoles et est certain de
pouvoir compter sur leur patrimoine et
leur descendance afin d'assurer leur
subsistance
quand les blessures du corps se rappeler
à leur bon souvenir ils vivent
aujourd'hui souvent seuls avec leur
conjoint leur pension de retraite
constituant leur unique pécule ainsi les
guère étonnant d'avoir assisté à une
forme de paupérisation des retraités
agricoles entraînant une angoisse un
sentiment de déclassement et
mécontentement de plus en plus
manifestes comme en témoigne tout
récemment la manifestation dernière par
l'association départementale du lot et
garonne
pour rappel il convient de mettre en
exergue que la retraite moyenne d'un
agriculteur est de 800 euros tandis que
celle de sa conjointe et de 500 euros
dans les deux cas les pensions se
situent sous le seuil de pauvreté fixé à
964 euros
pour pallier cette situation affligeante
le candidat françois hollande
fidèle à son principe ordonnateur de
justice sociale avait soumis pendant la
campagne présidentielle un plan
quinquennal évalué à 650 millions
d'euros
parmi les idées avancées figuraient
plusieurs points la mise à niveau à 75%
du smic des retraites des carrières
complètes des chefs d'exploitation
prévus par la loi perron de 2002 que les
gouvernements précédents n'ont pas su
mettre en oeuvre elle serait de nature à
améliorer les conditions de vie de plus
d'un million et demi de retraités non
salariés agricoles
la suppression de la condition de durée
d'activité minimale
monsieur tanner posez votre question
s'il vous prend fin de majorer la
majoration de passion l'extension de la
retraite complémentaire obligatoire aux
conjoints et aux aides familiaux pour
les retraités actuels dans la mesure où
98% des conjoints sont des femmes
l'introduction d'une telle disposition
serait une mesure la pwa salvatrice et
de justice qui profiterait à 45000
personnes par conséquent nous aimerions
connaître madame la ministre
les éventuelles retombées de ce plan
dédié aux exploitants agricoles qui
participe à hauteur de trois et demi
pour cent à notre richesse nationale
par ailleurs le cadre la future réforme
des retraites
d'autres pistes de réflexion sont l
explorer madame la ministre vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur teulade il est vrai que la
situation des exploitants agricoles et
de leurs conjoints doit être posée à
l'occasion de cette réforme des
retraites puisque depuis dix ans les
retraités agricoles ont été les grands
oubliés des politiques sociales et donc
nous devons aujourd'hui renouer avec ce
qui avait été la ligne de conduite du
gouvernement de lionel jospin qui avait
fait de la justice et la dignité des
retraités agricoles un des axes forts de
sa politique
nous devons en particulier je vous
remercie de l'avoir souligné nous devons
en particulier être attentif à la
situation des femmes d'exploitants
agricoles qui ont souvent beaucoup
travailler sans contrepartie financière
et sans reconnaissance du moins de la
part des institutions et des organismes
de la sécurité sociale avec stéphane le
foll le ministre de l'agriculture et
après avoir reçu différentes
organisations représentant les
exploitants et anciens exploitants nous
avons engagé dès l'été dernier la mise
en oeuvre d'engagements pris par le
président de la république françois
hollande c'est ainsi que dès la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 a été mise en oeuvre une mesure qui
permet aux exploitants agricoles qui ont
dû cesser leurs activités en raison
d'une maladie ou d'une infirmité graves
de bénéficier d'une validation au titre
de la retraite proportionnelle des
agriculteurs ainsi que de l'attribution
d'un nombre minimal de points gratuits
cette mesure opérante s'applique d'elle
depuis le 1er janvier dernier au delà
d'autres mesures devront traite devront
être prises dans le cadre de la réforme
qui s'engage notamment en direction des
femmes et des pensionnés les plus
modestes
nous devons
là encore à l'occasion de la réforme
globale que nous engageons avoir la
volonté de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas de catégories sociales oublier une
très forte réplique monsieur teulade
entendu madame la ministre je ne peux
qu'approuver les décisions qui
pourraient être prises j'ai participé ce
matin à une conférence parlementaire en
particulier sur la réforme des retraites
et je vois que toutes les mesures qui se
dessine ne vont dans le sens de ce que
souhaite effectivement disons ceux qui
n'ont pas jusqu alors pu bénéficier de
cette équité qui avaient été promises
par le président de la république et que
je l'espère seront tenus mais nous en
sommes persuadés
alors merci pour votre intervention il
ne reste plus qu'à attendre maintenant
que la réforme des retraites puisse
effectivement se concrétiser la parole
est à madame isabelle debré pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues malgré les
réformes courageuses des précédents
gouvernements réforme constamment
critiquée par la gauche
notre système de retraite fera
rapidement face à des déséquilibres
financiers très importants
ceci en partie dû à la dégradation
considérable de la conjoncture
économique les besoins de financement de
l'assurance vieillesse qui s'élevait à
14 milliards en 2011 seront de 20
milliards en 2020 selon le conseil
d'orientation des retraites
l'heure n'est plus mes chers collègues
aux tergiversations mais bien à la
nécessité de réfléchir ensemble un
système moins complexes juste et
efficace nous savons combien ce sujet
est difficile et qu'il nécessite courage
concertation et détermination vous avez
combattu toutes les réformes des
retraites que les précédents
gouvernements ont voulu élaborer
alors que la question était posée depuis
le gouvernement de michel rocard au
début des années 90 sans que la gauche
lorsqu'elle était au pouvoir ait pris la
moindre initiative en ce domaine
il n'est pas dans nos intentions de nous
opposer systématiquement aux
propositions qui seront des pâtes
car ce sujet est majeur pour notre pays
pour l'avenir de nos enfants
à la lumière des nombreux rapports
établis par les experts auxquels
s'ajoutera celui de la commission
présidée par madame moreau et dans le
contexte actuel marqué par un taux de
chômage jamais atteint un coût du
travail trop élevé et une pression
fiscale difficilement supportable pouvez
vous madame la ministre nous exposer
clairement les axes des réformes retenu
par le gouvernement
pouvez vous nous indiquer en particulier
si vous envisagez l'unification des
réformes de retraites du secteur public
et du secteur privé
vous n'avez pas répondu tout à l'heure
l'intégration des régimes spéciaux dans
le régime général ce que soulever mon
collègue gilbert barbier la transition
vers un système de retraite universel
par points
et bien sûr le report de l'âge légal de
la retraite
vous avez la parole madame un ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice debré
si j'entends bien ce que vous me dites
au fond l'opposition d'aujourd'hui
majorité d'hyères serait prête à
soutenir le gouvernement
dès lors qu'il s'engagerait dès lors
qu'il s'engagerait dans une réforme que
l'ump jugerait courageuse
est ce que l'ump juge courageux c'est ce
que l'ump d'hier n'a pas réalisé parce
que ce que vous venez de dire à
l'instant c'est au fond que ce qui doit
nous permettre ce qui doit nous
permettre d'apprécier si une réforme est
adapté ou pas c'est de savoir
premièrement si nous mettons en place
une rave une à un système par points
en 2010 la question du système par
points n'a pas été posée et a été écarté
et c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
la raison pour laquelle un rendez vous
en 2013 avaient été fixés pour faire une
évaluation de la situation destiné à
produire un rapport monsieur le sénateur
madame la sénatrice deuxième point vous
m'expliquer que une réforme des
retraites au fond ça se limite à la
question somme toute assez sommaire
de celle du service public comme si la
seule question à laquelle nous étions
confrontés était de savoir si les règles
qui s'appliquent à la fonction publique
était de même nature ou non que celle
qui s'applique au secteur privé nous
avons la volonté madame la sénatrice de
prendre à bras le corps la situation que
vous nous avez laissé je les dis nous
voulons que la réforme qui s'engagent ne
soit pas simplement une réforme
comptable car l'exemple de 2010 est là
pour le prouver
à vouloir simplement mettre en place des
mesures de rééquilibrage financier à
court terme on s'expose à de tristes
déconvenues et nous nous sommes
retrouvés dès 2013 avec un déficit des
régimes de retraite de l'ordre de 14
milliards d'euros alors que nous étions
censés trouver des déficits qui avait
disparu nous avons donc la volonté
madame la sénatrice d'engager une
réforme qui soit une réforme volontaires
qui s'inscrivent dans la durée et qui
permettent de concilier exigences
sociales responsabilités financières
madame debré pour une réplique madame la
ministre je suis vraiment un petit peu
surprise de cette caricature et surtout
je vous ai posé quatre questions
extrêmement précise et malheureusement
vous n'avez répondu à aucune des
questions alors ce que j'espère madame
le ministre
vous dites vouloir écouter écouterez
vous les français qui ce matin vous
l'avez vu dans un sondage à 52 %
préfèrent l'allongement de la durée de
travail plutôt que l'augmentation des
cotisations écouterez vous le président
la république qui a dit je le cite on
vit plus longtemps on doit donc
travailler plus longtemps est enfin
madame le ministre
et enfin madame la ministre je trouve
que cette réforme commence un peu mal
ici au sénat a été voté au point de vue
d'assurer le sujet des retraites
une proposition de loi permettant le
cumul de ce qu'on a appelé le minimum
vieillesse c'est à dire la spa avec une
revenus d'activité vous nous dites qu'il
ya des toutes petites retraites et que
vous voulez vraiment aider ces petites
retraites
cette proposition de loi a été voté au
sénat et vous allez france en ce qu'elle
ne soit pas l'assemblée nationale et
nous en sommes tous ici vraiment désolé
et ça prouve encore une fois
peut-être que votre
c'est un peu choquant parce que vous ne
trouvez pas les moyens de faire en sorte
qu'une proposition de loi simple humaine
efficace de bon sens et qui est
d'associations hilarité je vous remercie
la parole est à madame gisèle printz
pour le groupe socialiste remix merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
la dernière réforme des retraites de
2010 voulues par la droite était brutale
injuste et inefficace
la droite nous annoncer un retour à
l'équilibré pour 2010 est un rendez vous
pour 2013
aujourd'hui nous le savons en 2000 date
déficit atteindra 20 milliards d'euros
est le rendez vous de 2013 sera
l'occasion d'une nouvelle réforme
cette réforme indispensable le président
de la république l'avait guidé par des
principes de justice de responsabilité
et de concertation madame la ministre
vous avez quant à vous préciser qu'elle
poursuivra trois objectifs
l' équilibre financier à court terme la
pérennité du modèle par répartition à
moyen terme et des mesures de justice
nous savons que la concertation fait
partie intégrante de la méthodologie du
gouvernement la conférence sociale du
mois de juillet dernier
les accords nationaux
interprofessionnels en dessous des
exemples nous savons que sur les
retraites le gouvernement a appelé à la
table des négociations des partenaires
sociaux et que dès ce lundi le premier
ministre les a tous reçu nous avons
aussi que les conclusions du rapport de
madame oro qui sera demain remis au
premier ministre ne sont que des pistes
etc en aucun cas alain constitue le
socle de la concertation à venir a
fortiori à ne sont en aucun cas la
préfiguration d'une réforme bouclé comme
vous l'avez précisé la ministre monsieur
me voir disait que la retraite était une
ligne de vie une espérance de vie avec
le décret du 2 juillet dernier
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la république
le gouvernement assure donner corps à
cette ligne de vie pour des dizaines de
milliers de nos concitoyens ayant
commencé à travailler tôt et je ne peux
que m'en féliciter
compte tenu de la complexité que revêt
lé 2
des retraites les sujets d'importance
sont nombreux pour autant sans piétiner
sur les conclusions du rapport de madame
moreau ni sur les travaux à venir des
partenaires sociaux je souhaiterais que
vous puissiez nous éclairer sur le degré
de priorité qu'occupe des thèmes tels
que la pénibilité que la droite et le
patronat ont toujours refusé de traiter
sauf sous l'angle de la validité les
inégalités entre hommes et femmes qui
selon la cnam génère une différence
moyenne dame août de pan sur deux 42% et
la prise en compte des carrières hachées
vous avez la parole madame liste sur le
président madame la sénatrice izel
prince
vous avez parfaitement raison de
rappeler qu'une réforme quelle qu'elle
soit une réforme sociale une réforme des
retraites en particulier ne peut que se
concevoir avec la concertation et donc
lorsque l'opposition demande que l'on
apporte des réponses précises
immédiatement alors même que la
concertation ne s'est pas engagée au
fond on voit bien là la différence de
méthode qui lie à entre ceux qui veulent
la précipitation et les réformes votées
au milieu de l'été et ceux qui
s'engagent dans le dialogue et
l'élaboration concertée de propositions
pour l'avenir c'est parce que sans doute
vous avez l'expérience de l'absence de
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux que vous imaginez que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui est en mesure
d'apporter des solutions alors même que
les discussions ne se sont pas engagés
mais vous avez raison de souligner aussi
madame la sénatrice que la réforme que
nous devons présenter au parlement doit
être une réforme de justice qui
permettent d'apporter des réponses à des
situations comme celle des femmes dont
le niveau de pension reste inférieur de
façon très significative à celui des
hommes
nous devons prendre en compte les
carrières hachées la pénibilité du
travail
là où le gouvernement précédent a refusé
obstinément
de s'y atteler préférant donner une
approche purement médical de la
pénibilité
nous avons donc la volonté que la
question de la pénibilité
la question de la retraite des femmes la
question des carrières hachées la
question de l'emploi des seniors
puissent être posée ainsi que de
l'entrée dans la vie active des jeunes
qui doivent pouvoir savoir comment ils
vont construire leur carrière dans la
perspective d'une retraite future
nous voulons que l'ensemble de ces
questions soient sur la table et
trouvent des réponses positives
constructive et juste c'est l'esprit
dans lequel le gouvernement aujourd'hui
à engager son travail
matt madame prins si vous souhaitez
reprendre la parole aux jeux
madame la ministre je vous remercie pour
vos propos et je suis d'accord avec eux
je pense que la chose de principal quand
on débattra des du thème des retraites
des tensions et des réformes à y
apporter c'est de faire en concertation
avec tout le monde et le suivi de de la
pénibilité et du travail des inégalités
salariales premier femme est quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur et je pense
que vous nous apporter les bonnes
réponses
la parole est un monsieur jean louis
masson pour la réunion administrative
des sénateurs de figurants passe oui sur
la figure sur la liste d'aucun groupe
voilà madame le ministre
on parle beaucoup de justice d'efforts
partagés avec équité et systématiquement
on parle des fonctionnaires mais il faut
quand même voir que beaucoup de
gouvernements qui sont succédé ont parlé
aussi des fonctionnaires mais presque
tout le monde a fait semblant d'oublier
les régimes spéciaux
or là où se trouve la situation la plus
anormale la plus disproportionnées
notamment par rapport au régime général
eh bien ce sont les régimes spéciaux et
il faut le reconnaître les régimes
spéciaux ont facteur de dissuasion par
des menaces de grève et cetera mais est
ce que madame le ministre telle ou telle
corporation soupe aux thèses qu'elle
peut bloquer toute la france en faisant
une grève est en gênant tout le monde a
le droit au moment où l'on demande des
efforts à tout le monde en matière de
retraite a le droit de bénéficier
davantage tout à fait disproportionnée
aussi bien disproportionnée aussi bien
par rapport aux fonctionnaires que bien
entendu par autun par rapport au régime
général
alors il faut quand même être un peu
plus clair madame le ministre sur ce
problème des régimes spéciaux à et
j'aimerais bien que vous soyez précise
en la matière sur vos sur vos intentions
ma deuxième remarque madame le ministre
c'est pour vous dire et d'autres l'ont
dit avant moi que la solution c'est
avant tout la solution d'équité c'est
avant tout le système de retraite par
points et là aussi vous est pour le
moins évasive et si on met un régime de
retraite par points eh bien madame le
ministre il ya plus de problème de
dissocier les fonctionnaires il ya plus
de problème de régimes spéciaux
tout le monde est dans le même système
et donc à ce moment là on est vraiment
dans l'équité alors madame le ministre
pour vous le problème c'est pas de
parler d'équité c'est de faire les
quitter et ça au lieu de parler il
faudrait agir et je devrais en terminer
en rendant hommage
je voudrais en terminer en rendant
hommage à la cfdt qui est un des rares
syndicat à avoir le courage de ses
opinions et à ne pas faire de la
démagogie comme hélas beaucoup d'autres
son syndicat le fond en est ainsi c'est
systématiquement contre tout en sachant
très bien qu'on va dans le mur mais en
fermant les yeux produirait après après
nous les mouches
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
si monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur masson que dois-je faire ici
monsieur le sénateur je suis au
parlement et il me semblait que j'étais
venu vous parler et donc puisque je dois
vous parler
je voudrais pouvoir utiliser
les mots qui vont être ce que nous
allons poser sur la réforme que nous
élaborons parce que monsieur le sénateur
larcher les paroles sont toujours
verbale et donc nous allons ensuite
écrire un texte de loi dont vous aurez à
débattre et qui montrera que nous avons
la volonté d'inscrire nos régimes de
retraite dans la durée vous avez posé
beaucoup de questions monsieur le
sénateur vous savez ça n'est pas en
appliquant nécessairement les mêmes
règles à des situations différentes que
l'on aboutit à la plus grande équité
je voudrais revenir sur la question par
exemple des droits familiaux
nous constatons que sur les droits
familiaux ils sont plus avantageux dans
le secteur privé que dans la fonction
publique et dans les régimes spéciaux
on pourrait remarquer que les
fonctionnaires partant en retraite avec
une retraite qui est calculée à partir
de leurs salaires indépendamment de
toute prise en compte des primes ce qui
aboutit à des différences tout à fait
significatives et donc je crois que
l'objectif qui doit être le nôtre et 7
ans en tout cas celui du gouvernement
c'est de faire en sorte que l'effort
demandé à chacun soit le même que
l'effort demandé à l'ensemble des
catégories soit de même nature et que le
niveau des pensions versées soit un
niveau acceptable pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
en contrepartie d'un effort qui doit
être évidemment de même nature cet
effort
il représente l'effort que nous allons
demander aux français pour pouvoir
garantir la pérennité de nos systèmes de
retraites pour ce qui est du système par
points j'ai eu l'occasion d'indiquer que
ça n'est pas la recette qui va nous
permettre de sortir des difficultés
encore une fois à l'exemple le plus
abouti le plus intéressant est
incontestablement le mieux structuré et
celui qui a été mis en place au cours
d'une période très longue d'ailleurs il
a fallu quinze ans pour que la suède met
en place un système par points
dans ce pays et qui existent m qui a
abouti à une dégradation très forte au
cours des dernières années des pensions
des suédois vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur ce qui parfois apparaît comme
une solution miracle se révèle à
l'arrivée un miroir aux alouettes
monsieur jean louis masson pour une
réplique oui mesdames le ministre vos
réponses sont égale à elle-même car
disons elles sont pas plus précise
j'espérais que peut-être le saint-esprit
tomberez sur votre réponse et que
j'aurais parfois ma foi une réponse mais
là là véritablement disons vous êtes
dedans vous êtes dans vos réponses et
gala vous même mais en jouant simplement
vous dire que votre d'abord vous n'avez
pas répondu sur un gym spéciaux ce qui
est quand même affligeant c'est un
manque de courage madame le ministre
et puis d'autre part vous n'avez vous
avez rejeté le système des retraites
parfois on dit dans tous les cas sont
différents mais madame le ministre
il faut quand même et honnêtes dans
cette affaire-là est-ce que disons la
situation d'un chauffeur de poids lourd
qui travaillent dans le privé à qui j ai
jamais chez lui qui roule la nuit le
jour et cetera est tellement différente
de la situation d'un conducteur de
locomotive est ce que madame le ministre
un employé ddf qui plante en été
quelques poteaux télégraphiques quelques
poteaux électriques
quelques poteaux électriques est
tellement dans une situation différente
de l'employé d'une entreprise publique
qui creusent des tranchées
été comme hiver et et qui a des horaires
beaucoup plus vite alors je crois qu'il
faut pas qu'on se voit son nom j'en
termine monsieur criant je pense ne pas
dire n'importe quoi et que ma foi il ya
un vrai problème à ce niveau là et faire
semblant de croire qu'il ya pas de
problème
c'est un peu se moquer des français bien
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h pour l'examen de la suite
de la proposition de loi autorisant
l'expérimentation des maisons de
naissance la séance est suspendue
vous venez de suivre en direct les
traditionnelles questions cribles au
sénat merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
ne le manquez pas à 19h le journal de
michel grossiord bonne après midi à tous
donc je
peu
on connaît son vieux port ses calanques
son équipe de foot ces règlements de
comptes mais marseille ville millénaire
ne veut pas se laisser caricaturer et
devient pour un an
capitale européenne de la culture
l'occasion de découvrir d'autres
facettes de cette ville multiculturelle
et peut-être pour la cité phocéenne
deuxième ville de france de changer
l'image qui lui colle à la peau
je vous en
et
itinéraire bis le magazine curieux des
gens est proche de chez vous vous emmène
à marseille marseille devenue capitale
européenne de la culture
800 événements 60 expositions un nouveau
musée est une ville qui change de peau
pour ce numéro exceptionnel rencontre
avec trois figures de marseille et
michel cordes de plus belle la vie
rudy ricciotti l'architecte du nouveau
musée ou encore anne marie tagawa elle
est éducatrice dans les quartiers nord
trois regards croisés sur la place de la
culture dans notre vie
chaque soir ils sont près de 6 millions
à se donner rendez vous ici dans le
quartier du mistral le quartier
imaginaire des habitants de plus belle
la vie
neuf ans plus de 2000 épisodes un succès
qui ne se dément pas un morceau de
marseille pour beaucoup de français
on va tout de suite voir ce que c'est il
est l'un des visages les plus connus de
la série michel corre de nous reçoit la
terrasse de son bistrot est avec nous il
revient sur le succès d'une série
tournée dans un quartier de marseille
entièrement reconstituée en studio
nous y voici dans le quartier du mistral
michel corre bonjour bonjour ou bien
doit je vous appelez roland alors
l'acteur c'est michel et le personnage
c'est roland mais c'est vrai que pour
beaucoup de gens ça fait un seul paquet
9 ans à vivre ici faire vivre marseille
dans le quartier du mistral est toujours
le même succès comment vous expliquez ça
il ya un lien affectif très fort il ya
le fait que le feuilleton représente
probablement assez bien la société
française et que donc beaucoup de gens
s'y retrouvent à contrer des lettres de
fans qui sont inouïes le vieux monsieur
dont on a affalé morte
tous les matins il a sur la tombe de sa
famille raconte l'épisode de la veille
parce qu'il l'a regardé parce qu'il
regardait ensemble alors vous êtes vous
l'un des personnages principaux de cette
série vous êtes là depuis le début
vous êtes le patron du bar du mistral
et là on y est en plein coeur c'est
l'endroit où tous les personnages se
croisent c'est ici que tout se passe
comme dans la vraie vie vive le bar
c'est encore là où où tout se passe je
vous dirais une chose c'est qu'on est
quand même en france et le bistrot en
france
c'était incontournable c'est aussi je
dirais dans la fonction de rabat tuerie
si vous aimez les grands mots c'est un
lieu où des tas de gens peuvent se
retrouver
c'est ça aussi ça permet de faire
arriver des gens qui viennent de tous
les milieux qui de tous les âges etc
je vous propose qu'on aille faire un
tour parce que là il ya le tournage qui
va commencer
c'est parti
michel nous voici dans ce lieu où sont
fabriqués tous les décors et où sont
entreposés les accessoires de la série
c'est bien ça voilà c'est ça donc ici
vous avez de la déco bien sûr et à
l'intérieur de la découpe je dirais que
vous avez la somme de vie des
personnages de chacun et ça c'est le
petit tiroir de roland la soirée choses
qui sont typiques de rolande regarder
voilà il ya une femme qui l'a beaucoup
aimé voilà ben on peut retrouver
tu vois pas son portable mais il a son
portable voilà il assemble vous vous
sentez marseillais méridionale or cette
scène vous avez le petit accent vous
êtes le seul finalement tout est lisse
et sinon oui alors je sais pas
réellement marseillais d'origine mais je
suis vraiment n l'accent ne l'est pas
contrefaits voilà je suis peut-être plus
languedocien que provençal mais ça passe
à fait pas une grande différence
marseille est aux couleurs de la culture
avec cet événement marseille provence
2013 parce que vous allez en parler
ou est-ce que vous en avez parlé dans la
série on va en parler je sais qu'il y a
été fait allusion
et je pense mais nous nous découvrons
les intrigue assez tard à cet art oui et
bien évidemment quand on nous donne les
textes mais je pense qu'ils savent à
être traitée oui vous personnellement
vous avez accueilli cette nouvelle avec
curiosité en train moi j'ai été